è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vigente oggi siamo
sul nuovo video prima di cominciare
ragazzi un'offerta piccola premessa
prima in te quello che state vedendo
oggi un tipo di videogame diverso dal
solito
io voglio fare in questione sono due
direi di partire dal primo che è il più
strano così non vi lascio sulle spine di
20 ragazzi questo so questo sorti m a
come una sorta di film mad dog poiche
controlli 2 genoa sto aspettarlo per
limiti una figata pazzesca che volevo
assolutamente fare
io non ho ancora visto bene proprio quel
poco che ho vista una figata questo
tizio che abbiamo giovane amiche mi
piacerebbe se si fallisce e cosa ci
facciamo è su questa barca lei ha
portato fa vice fare un bel viaggetto mi
piace tornare ai ragazzi famigie oggi mi
insegnerà a pescare nel modo più giusto
ma dove ci sto più senso tirando cavi a
caso perché cazzo o no cosa sia andato
storto
cazzo andato storto la sua caviglia
attenzione merda l'egide uomi mar nuovi
schermi tal stopping to stay the surface
ok merda merda per te l'eri il musetto
ragazzo amico mio lì qui julien sharks
con me vieni qui lorido strattone faccia
male
presto negandole mette poi capo è
difficilissimo ragazzino tenendo stare
così col mouse pad allarmismo
impossibile charles giorno ride lui
doppi sente vieni qui struzzo né
lasciato mi sta lasciando nega no non ci
voglio credere
lui il resto francese io non sono
razzista però va a fan culo chance dove
cazzo vital rimasto nella merda lega
perfetto sono sosta nas pando fa il lato
ragazzi io quest'anno non ve lo volevo
dire però in teoria questa è una cosa
sto facendo non lo so cosa sta facendo
il cappato la evidente con la mia donna
sto stronzo
io io non volevo dirvelo ragazzi però in
teoria questa cosa ho deciso di farla
per l'italia questa è una e una delle
mie paure più profonde seriamente essere
abbandonato nell'oceano in una delle
cose più brutte che potesse mai successo
è uno dei miei incubi più profondi
praticamente sicuro che sta cosa non
dovevo dirlo perché qualcuno prima o poi
mi rapisce mi portando qualche parte in
mezzo l'oceano cazzo ragazzi sto poi
andrea baffo si tocca il piede a si sta
staccando nascar perché titoli e scarpe
cosa sto negando merda vaffanc orchards
torna indietro non lo vedo già più porca
[ __ ] io vi giuro che a rimanere a galla
e una me un casino della madonna merda
merda che cazzo
poiché sono riuscito per la per grazia
di dio ci sono riuscito una notte
capitana ma è difficilissimo a [ __ ]
torna su borghi eccoli perfetto ancora
france è liberté fraternité tua sorella
che questo tema perché su misto
massaggiando le gambe che cazzo fai uno
c'è uno che sta nell oceano su perduto
si massaggia le gambe mi sembra giusto
se il dm merda merda merda è la parola
john nerd merda denti mai ma sono
annaspare con un minchione noi che provi
a nuotare niente si tocca i pietro
agazzi nel caso rimanesse in questa
situazione di forza ricordatevi di
toccarvi piedi perché chi giovi salva la
vita il tema una bassa e una barca è un
elicottero qualcosa del genere novero
perché sono stronzi noi
perfetto allora io continua a rimanere
mezzo sott'acqua mezzo secolo importante
che non arrivino squali sono solo nella
merda che cazzo forse sta giocando al
gioco del pollice è quello bello
fantastico utili che fanno me senti
amico
invece di fare il [ __ ] è un bravo ha
iniziato a nuotare lega ci ha messo tipo
45 minuti però sono progressi dai a e
fratello fratello di mr cos'è fermi
perché mi sono distratta e gli strazi
mare ragazzi sono nella merda madonna
geografica sia l'unica cosa bella di sta
roba che c'è una grafica della madonna
lo sto facendo ma che schifo ma che
cazzo fare
fabbrica così togliere un caso no non
hanno vinto buongiorno giorgio bongiorno
si fa vince ma se n'è andato perfetto
che cazzo non devono non devo cedere
devo stare calmo bravo questo è lo
spirito giusto non staccarsi l'unghia è
neanche massaggiarsi piedi è no perchè
questo io io non lo perdono d'occhio si
massaggia i piedi ma scegli del cazzo
datemi la ma qualcuno mi dia una mano
sono riuscito a rimanere non chiedete in
corso riuscito a rimanere a galla di te
e qualcuno mi da una mano perché sono
ancora in mezzo all'oceano e per caso
incontro nemo qualcosa del genere noè
sipro torna su tornate veloci e torna su
brega cazzo ma sei stupido io io io sono
andato su esegui che deficente non è un
ragazzo cosa non l'ho capito cosa sta
succedendo ragazzi sto nascondo remoto
che quel fondo se se sei affogato dopo 4
minuti e 46 secondi fantastic ragazzi e
era e in mare tutto più veloce di quanto
pensi anche tua sorella più veloce di
quanto pensi ovunque tu vada porta c'è
una giacchetta
io avrei in consiglio migliore non
andare mai coi francesi in barca fai
prima perfetto ragazzi siamo sul secondo
the burning rom è una cosa allora fermi
un attimo che è un po un casino si
promette che se poi lo stesso stile di
io l'ho lasciato acceso il forno e son
cazzi vostri poi ma che poi dato la
colpa né per qualsiasi cosa
finito grazie la regale non l'ho capito
sta che il gatto è successo ma è un
attimino che non ho capito il prossimo
anno come prima che stava fermo lo ha
mica questo un casino sentite cosa click
qui salve non lo sai mamma tu però che
se sei una ragazzina fissa brutti se non
assenti i miei mi accende il televisore
in full hd che cioè di fianco no perché
volevo vedere un film in 3d solo che non
ci sei tu alla televisione
sì ma stai tranquillo che si articola il
trucco o piangi nero una delle due treni
non tocco di classe però anche una
scatola faccio una scarpa io clicco
sulla giustamente salve io acc entro e
l'asia che cazzo sono un mago sono
entrato dentro mamma c'è qualcuno che
bussa alla porta mamma ma poi tu io non
apro cazzo raga io non ha proprio una
serie no dopo questo
non ti cazzo di volte ho detto che non
si fuma in casa quant'è madonna che
bella lampada hanno capito se sono cotto
a puntino sostanza cosa io la non ci
voglio andare
scusate io non ci va faccio
qualcos'altro a mi arrampico sui muri
madonna che bei muri
così mi siedo su questo bel divano e mi
e vino e vi racconto una favola perché
non si può andare avanti così sentite
fatemi entrare prima che si cimenta di
tutto ci sono già che afa sto facendo
una cagata però devo farlo perché non
posso cliccare per andare avanti anche
ancora mai rotto il cazzo è a sentire il
prodotto il cazzo sempre più di mezzo
non volevo dirtelo no no io no io non
clinton in un click on a segare non
avete capito io io clicco qualsiasi
qualsiasi [ __ ] cosa tranne questa la
facciamo una bella cosa
al mio tre clicco copritevi gli occhi
faccio anch'io perché no ora due break
burqa tuca tuca non l'ho vista non l'ho
vista non lo so non me ne frega niente
purtroppo i nel video perché non ci
aveva senso cioè non possono primi di
infarti così davanti perché lievito non
ha senso
sentite bei bambini io io io avrei
vorrei cliccare su di voi però so già
che succede qualcosa di brutto
no non fumare forse perché si chiama the
burning rom
adesso c'è un senso saldo posso si
scommette con la volete vanno a fuoco le
scale ok ok calmi lega io mi sento
addosso camicie con aroma fuoco e sta
tizia ok al bebè the burning rom
meraviglioso ragazzi madaya parti scazzi
mi piace un casino i videogiochi cosi e
stato e stato fantastico da parte tua
parte la gente che va a fuoco però vabbè
sicura d'inverno non stanno al fresco
provano ipotesi questi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto il documento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come ogni
video fratena descrizione per server si
discreta e nocive sono forse ho visto
bene ragazzi